[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si je devais retourner à l'école je m'y
opposerai de toutes mes forces mon
parcours a été biaisé pendant ma
scolarité de nombreuses incompréhensions
ont fortement contribué à mon décrochage
aujourd'hui et j'assimile cette époque à
des expériences épineuses
particulièrement dans mon rapport avec
les autres je ne supportais pas le bruit
la communication avec mes camarades
était difficile pour moi impossible de
faire du par cœur ou de poser des
équation sans leur donner du
sens comportement atypique attitude
taciturne je passais pour inadapté
retardé voire déficient au fil de ces
années mon désir d'apprendre au sein de
cet environnement s'est peu à peu
dissipé aux yeux des enseignants et de
mes camarades les signes d'un haut
ccient intellectuel étaient
insoupçonnable pourtant le diagnostic
avait bel et bien a été posé le monde
devenait brutal pour moi seement le
doute sur mes
[Musique]
capacités est-ce que c'est important de
savoir lire et écrire oui qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire quand on sait lire on
peut raconter des histoires aux
enfants la plupart des enfants quand ils
sont d'origine socioéconomique
modeste même s'ils sont précoces à l'âge
de 5 ans et bien échouent dans plus de
50 % des cas ce sont des enfants voués à
l'échec quand un enfant intelligent
s'ennuie en classe il peut devenir
instable d'autres s'endorment c'était
simplement des enfants qui s'ennuyai et
qui avait besoin qu'on leur propose à
leur rythme des activités qui qui les
amusent et qui
les qui les alimente sur le plan
intellectuel en France ce sujet du haut
potentiel a eu beaucoup de mal à percer
en fait à la suite de Mai 68 on a
considéré que s'intéresser aux enfants
qui seraient les plus intelligents
c'était faire une forme d'élitisme
Jean-Charles terassier psychologue
pionnier en France dans la problématique
du haut potentiel met en place un
dispositif d'intégration à l'attention
de ses enfants selon les académies il
représente un élève sur 20 soit un à
deux élèves par classe c'est dans un
quartier populaire de Nice qu'une classe
spécifique voit le jour en
1987 une première prise de conscience
c'est seulement 20 ans plus tard que le
dispositif d'intégration des élèves à
haut potentiel se développe sous sa
forme
actuelle à cette époque j'achevais ma
scolarité mon envie de découvrir la
situation de ces élèves aujourd'hui et
les différents échecs rencontrés au
cours de ces années m'ont longtemps
interrogés l'encadrement proposé
m'aurait-il permis d'envisager autrement
l'histoire douloureuse que j'ai
entretenu avec le système
scolaire
[Musique]
l'égalité des chances c'est pas toujours
essayer de faire rentrer tout le monde
dans le mou c'est aussi respecter le
rythme de développement de
chacun l'intelligence ça se mesure pas
comme la température c'est pas une
mesure qui est
sûre il y a pas vraiment de consensus
dans la façon de les appeler on peut
entendre précoce
surdouer depuis quelques années c'est
plus au potentiel intellectuel qui est
privilégié moi que observe c'est que il
y a d'un côté les compétences
intellectuelles et de l'autre côté la
souffrance psychique le haut potentiel
ne génère pas de souffrance parce que le
haut potentiel ne parle que de
d'intelligence et l'intelligence ne
génère pas
d'anxiété je dérangeais en fait mes
camarades parce que je m'ennuyais en
fait je suis pas super intelligent je
suis pas le premier de ma classe j'ai
juste la moyenne de ma classe en fait il
y a des enfants préc qui ont des très
mauvaises notes il a des enfants
précoces qui ont des très bonnes notes
mais moi personnellement faut que je
travaille pour les avoir pour beaucoup
précocité égale très bon élève et c'est
parfois le cas mais c'est pas toujours
le
cas j'ai grandi dans les années 90 dans
une petite blieue de la région
parisienne c'est à cette époque que j'ai
commencé à développer mon
imaginaire
[Musique]
très vite je me suis rendu compte de la
nécessité de me fondre dans le moule en
ayant des sens d'intérêts commun avec
mes
camarades sauf que se déguiser est comme
mettre un masque mon attitude tassiturne
me trahit je m'isole de plus en plus et
je me fais oublier de nombreuses
désillusions sont apparues laissant
place un grand sentiment d'échec et
[Musique]
d'isolement
c'est ainsi que cette période s'est
déroulé parfois j'entends encore ces
voix qui risonnait le dimanche
midi qu'il
encoreit ça va pas toujours être comme
ça Mar tu pouris
faire qu-ce qu'on va faire
de un sentiment d'incompréhension
d'injustice me pouss à l'abandon au
désinvestissement de l'apprentissage de
fil en aiguille collis à l'image qu'on
se faisait de moi en rendant des copies
blanches malgré les apparences quand
j'avais 10 ans j'écoutais des émissions
politique à la radio toute la nuit je
suivais les élections et me passionnais
pour les films de campagne
électorale pendant que mes camarades
regardaient des dessin animés je lisais
libération l'équipe Mozart betov Vivaldi
j'étais incollable sur les compositeurs
de musique
classique certains enfants vont tomber
dans une forme de conformisme j'ai des
des jeunes garçon à haut potentiel qui
s'impose d'apprendre par cœur des
équipes de joueurs de foot parce que un
garçon en primaire qui s'intéresse pas
au foot c'est pas un
garçon le dieep c'est le dispositif
d'intégration des élèves à haut
potentiel il se retrouve dans les
classes ordinaires c'estàdire qu'ils
sont pas regroupés dans une classe
particulière pour faire partie du
dispositif il faut il faut avoir fait le
test il y a un incontournable c'est la
passation d'une épreve d'intelligence de
weschler c'est une une épreuve qui est
internationale qui est est reconnue dans
tous les pays on va explorer différents
domaines de l'intelligence la
compréhension verbale le raisonnement
visiospatial le raisonnement fluide la
logique mathématique la mémoire de
travail aussi et la vitesse de
traitement il faut avoir une moyenne de
130 au test
whisk mais ça c'est une condition
nécessaire mais pas suffisante pour être
admis dans le dispositif il faut avoir
eu des soucis aussi et parfois avec des
enseignants ou avec des camarades ils
ont pu être harcelés on reçoit des
profils très variés mais ils ont tous eu
ce point commun c'est-à-dire une
histoire un petit peu douloureuse avec
l'école au primaire c'est par le versant
des difficultés que l'école l'éducation
nationale on est arrivé à aborder le
sujet alors le revers de la médaille
c'est que à partir des années 90 il y a
eu du coup beaucoup de publications plus
ou moins scientifiquement fondé mais
justement mettant l'accent sur les
difficultés au point que récemment euh
on a pu accuser tout ce qui avait été
publié de de patologiser le haut
potentiel d'oublier aussi et c'est vrai
qu'il y a des personnes à haut potentiel
qui vont très bien ça a sorti de l'ombre
des les cancre en fait de
réenvisager les enfants avec un bonnet
d'âne au fond de la classe comme des
enfants potentiellement plus valeureux
qui pouvaient cacher des merveilles
certes certaines personnes à haut
potentiel vont très bien et par contre
c'est vrai qu'il y en a en a d'autres
qui ont des difficultés c'est important
de les
[Musique]
accompagner cm c'est c'était un
peu moi je compare un peu à à un jour
sans fin niveau scolaire ça allait mais
je m'ennuyais un petit peu en
classe parfois je me faisais des ami
mais il y a eu quelques histoires je
veux pe être ton ami je veux redevenir
ton ami
je me suis dit c'est pas possible on est
dans une c'est c'est c'est un film c'est
c'est c'est une pièce de théâtre c'est
pas possible c'est une comédie
oui c'est c'est c'est pas possible que
ça fasse il y a eu des moments où
c'était un peu comme ça dans ma
[Musique]
tête en fait ça commence par la
maternelle qui s'est pas bien passé pour
céser
euh beaucoup de difficultés dans dans
ses rapports avec ses camarades dans ses
rapports avec ses institutrices on t
embêté quand même h il commence à être
malheureux il revenais il dis j'ai passé
une journée comment tu disais pourri
comment tu disais j'ai passé une
horrible journée ouais ouais donc bon on
peut essayer de le travailler ça mais
bon à un moment il y a il y a quelque
chose qui va pas quoi h et puis dans ce
cas-là souvent le regard sur les parents
est un peu suspicieux parce qu'on
imagine que enfin moi c'est ce que je
ressentais que les parents ne ne
poussent pas leur enfant à suivre à
écouter moi on m'a plusieurs fois dit
laissz-le grandir
oui on sait qu'il est il se stresse
quand il a pas de temps il se stresse
quand il pense queil a pas assez préparé
quelque
chose mais bon ça
on on travaille quoi et puis on lui dit
puis on lui dit que c'est pas très
important pour revenir il y avait un
isolement quand même avant le di quand
même donc rien jusqu'à ce cette
fameuse rencontre en CE2 où il a été
détecté en 6e pour me réorienter on me
fait passer des tests psychométriques on
s'aperçoit que mon cootient intellectuel
est de
135 je garderai toujours en mémoire la
confusion crée par résultat autant pour
moi que pour la psychologue scolaire qui
ne comprenait pas le décalage avec les
remarques de mes professeurs mais
c'était trop tard j'avais beau avoir
surinvesti le domaine de la pensée
j'étais quand même en pro au doute j'ai
développé durant mon enfance des
difficultés relationnelles
organisationnel les attitudes qui ont
découlé me faisaient craindre le
jugement des autres renforçant mes
incertitudes
quand j'étais jeune psychologue et je
vais chercher la la salle d'attente un
enfant il était là avec sa maman il
était amimique il avait pas il exprimait
très peu et alors il avait tout le temps
la bouche
ouverte la première impression que vous
avez ça fait pas très malin et et il
venait difficulté à l'école et et ou là
là celui-là c'est il n'a pas l'air
d'être très je moi-même il n'a pas l'air
d'être réfuté dans l'entretien c'était
quelqu'un très inhibé qui parlait pas
beaucoup je dis bon on va quand mêmeire
passer un
[Musique]
test et en fait le gars il a fait plus
de 120 de cuilles et ça ça m'a fait
réfléchir parce que je crois qu'il faut
être très prudent parce que j'entends
parfois des gens qui me disent oui mais
moi je vois tout de suite si vous êtes
au potentiel ou pas ils se voient comme
ça ils ont l'impression son sont des
espèces de Devin euh ils oublient et ça
c'est quelque chose que j'ai appris
c'est que l'être humain n'est pas un
très bon observateur c'est pas du tout
une solution magique c'est vraiment au
cas par cas donc il faut avoir une une
démarche très déontologique dans
l'administration des tests qui quand
même ont été créés pour débusquer des
précisions sur les difficultés donc les
déficien les entraves cognitives he des
élèves au départ vesler et cetera ils
n'ont pas du tout créé des tests pour
alimenter le fantasme narcissique de
parents qui serait en quête d'un enfant
surdoué ou celui de de psyeux scrupuleux
qui viendrait s'enrichir sur le dos d'un
fantasme sur la socialisation des
enfants on a une salle qu'on appelle la
salle du diep qui est vraiment le
refuge c'est bien d'avoir une relation
un peu de confiance quand même à
l'intérieur du collège
j'ai le droit d'accéder à une salle une
salle du
DI quand je suis un peu énervé ou quand
je sens pas bien je peux aller au
JEP je pouvais parler je je pouvais
m'exprimer et du coup me calmer revenir
ens un pe plus tard pour j'ai la
pression alors ils peuvent y aller quand
ils veulent alors ils peuvent y aller
pour la récréation le midi mais même si
en cours ils ont ils éprouve le besoin
de sortir parce que émotionnellement
c'est compliqué ou ils peuvent aller
dans cette salle et c'est un peu la
salle où alors il retrouve un assistant
d'éducation mais il se retrouveve entre
eux aussi rien
cré alors on va faire un
petit je crois que ça va quand je suis
arrivé j'avais quand même une meilleure
idée des des problématiques soit des des
élèves très très insolents ou
multiexclus qui venaient qui venaient
souvent dans la salle ou des élèves qui
seraient assez assez discrets voir voir
harcelés oui c'est Adrien ouais c'était
pour te dire les Pavlova ils ont cours
le jeudi après de 14h à
18h en fait ce qui est paradoxal ouais
c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte qu'il
soit le moins ici possible quand il
viennent un peu en traînant des pieds
alors que ça a soné depuis une minute en
disant on m'a pas accepté ou j'ai pas
envie d'y aller c'est d'essayer de de
voir que ce caslà soit pas non
plus
récurrent ça c'est un des problèmes et
un des autres des autres soucis c'est
parfois de la gestion gestion
émotionnelle donc il y a des élèves qui
qui explosent un peu comme des petites
bombes à
retardement à peine la sonnerie retentit
c'est déjà la fin de la récrée les
groupes d'élèves se forment dans les
couloirs pourvu que la classe soit déjà
[Musique]
ouverte saisi par le brois qui augmente
on ne peut plus reculer maintenant il
n'y a pas le choix rester calme surtout
reste
calme
[Applaudissements]
compliqué d'Er la frontière entre ce
qu'on peut accepter qu'on peut pas
accepter en fait compliqué par qu'on
sait qu'ils ont une caractéristique qui
peut rendrait plus facilement des crises
par exemple et jusqu'à jusqu'ù on ouis
et pourquoi ça moi ma question pourquoi
ça des crises des gamins qui sont quand
même
sou une gamine qui fabrique des
bracelets c'est pareil en fait les
collègues l'autorisent à faire mais à
condition qu' suivent le cours bien sûr
il a toujours la condition pas son truc
et pu rien d'autre le droit de faire ses
bracelets parce que justement ça
probablement ça l'aide à ce qu' puisse
se concentrer ouais et du coup et c'est
moi j'ai regardé son buletin not parce
que je l' su en tutor 18 de moyenne
d'accord et pourtant elle fait ses
brasss en fait ça la pénalise pas vu
qu'elle a vraiment cette capacité à tout
retenir hyper rapidement donc ça je
pense ça fait partie des trucs qu'on
peut accepter oui nous on a un élève
aussi qui a besoin de faire du rubx
cube allez toujours la même consigne
vous m'inventez une petite phrase qui
contient une assonnance en qu'est-ce
qu'il y a I
[Applaudissements]
ouais
William et son frère Arthur William a 14
ans Arthur 11 à l'école primaire William
était timide et parfois bagarreur son
attitude inquiète à l'école comme au
sein de sa famille parents et enseignant
présentent un parcours très chaotique un
ultime incident a amené son entourage à
trouver une
solution je sais plus de quoi est parti
on s'est bagarré avec un élève il y
avait deux animateurs pour me retenir en
fait dans ce bureau et en fait à un
moment donné je j'ai réussi à m'évader à
m'enfuir et de là je voulais absolument
me venger entre guillemets
du de la personne en question au final
il a fallu trois adultes pour me
maîtriser on avait carrément enfermé
l'élève qui avait embêté William dans
cette dans une salle le
protéger ce moment qui m'a vraiment fait
comprendre qu'il y avait un problème
avec William qu' est qu'il était pas
comme les autres je l'avais déjà
remarqué mais maintenant j'en étais
sûr au cours de mon enfance j'ai le
souvenir d'avoir énormément intériorisé
au
quotidien tout comme William mon esprit
tourmenté rebuté mes camarades me
poussant à la faute je ne trouvais pas
le moyen d'expulser sainement mes
colères à l'école l'autorité était la
règle aucune possibilité d'être écouté
en tout cas c'est ce que je
[Musique]
ressentais j'essaie d'ignorer mais le
problème c'est que vu que j'ai changé de
place depuis je suis juste en face vous
êtes placé fait chaque élève du
dispositif a un tuteur qui est en
général un de ses professeurs il y a une
familiarité qui se fait entre le tuteur
et l'élèv au fil de
l'année je regarde la dernière note et
je vois 6/ 10 et je me dis bon ben
j'aurais pu faire mieux et cetera j'ai
j'étais un j'ai j'ai un peu pleuré à un
moment on a tous le droit de pleurer
mais essayez de de de prendre de plus en
plus sur vous pour intégrer la crise
essayer d'écrire comment vous avez
réussi à gérer d'accord là il a
l'occasion de d'exprimer tout ce qu'il
ressent par rapport à sa scolarité voilà
la parole est très libre le rôle du
tuteur c'est d'abord de d'écouter
l'élève Hippolyte il a c'est deux
classes donc c'est difficile il dit pour
les anniversaires parce qu'en fait il a
des amis en une première classe il en a
des dans une autre classe il en a encore
des en 6e donc son rôle aussi consiste à
jouer le rôle d'intermédiaire avec
d'autres professeurs quand il y a des
malentendus même si la plupart des
enseignants sont assez au fait des des
problématiques de la précocité dans le
collège les adultes surtout mon tuteur
enfin on comprend il y a pas de sujet
tabou enfin je peux lui parler de tout
tout tout ça allit un peu mieux parce
qu'ier ça allait pas du tout ben ouais
hier soir quand je suis rentré ça allait
mieux je pense c'était la la truc
d'espagnol qui me prenait bien la tête h
voilà je pense c'était surtout la
fatigue en grande
majorité mais sinon je sais pas
trop félicitation en tout cas ton
intuition elle s'est pas
vérifiée souviens de ce que tu m'as dit
non que quand tu étais dans cet étatl en
général il y avait des gros incidents
qui arriv ah oui bah écoute j'ai pris
sur moi h et comment tu as fait ça bah
je me suis juste dit
euh faut te calmer vouen faut pas faire
de conneries hein moi j'ai Cu vraiment
par contre au bout d'un moment tu allais
tu allais commencer à chercher un peu à
taquiner voir un peu la BAGAR pas l'avir
en peinture ouais mais en fait je me
reconnais en lui si tu vois ce que je
veux dire genre je sais ce qui se passe
dans sa tête pour qu'il fasse ça et
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans sa tête pour
qu' pour qu'il provoque comme ça
latention des gens c'est juste pour
avoir de la tenenstion
ouais j'étais pareil mais genre 3 ans de
moins tu vois ouais tu imagines mes
profs c'était avant avant le collège
ouais tu étais pas un peu comme ça quand
tu es arrivé bah j'étais comme ça quand
je suis arrivé mais j'étais encore pire
avant
j'avais pas vraiment d'amis en
élémentaire il y avait souvent des des
bagarres ou des disputes j'étais souvent
dans des histoires en fait j'étais dans
aucun groupe en fait j'étais tout seul
dans mon coin on en parlait avec les
enseignants on en parlait avec le le
directeur et on savait pas vraiment par
quel côté
l'abordit ce que je trouve aussi assez
mystérieux parfois et en tout cas très
intéressant c'est d'essayer de
comprendre comment des élèves qui ont
tout pour pour réussir se sentir bien à
l'école bah rencontre des des
difficultés à certains moments de leur
scolarité ça interroge l'école ça nous
interroge comme enseignant quand j'étais
enfant en fait j'ai j'étaé dans les deux
difficultés qu'ils ont eu difficulté à
gérer l'échec difficulté à gérer la
relation avec les autres j'ai redoublé
trois fois ça a été compliqué euh bon la
vie à la maison était pas facile non
plus mais en tout cas j'aurais pu être
détecé au potentiel à l'époque j'ai fait
le test étant adulte assez tardivement
je l'ai fait l'année dernière et donc ou
il y avait pas tout ça HP très potentiel
il dit au potentiel non il est très haut
potentiel je me suis un peu rattrapé sur
ma carrière professionnel tout
simplement mon premier bapthème de l'air
j'ai découvert que la vi c'était mon
truc quoi les sujets qui m'intéressaient
étai plus soit niveau lycée soit niveau
postback alors que j'étais juste au
collège et bah finalement le cours
continue à avancer vous vous êtes plus
là vous avez décroché vous écutez plus
et puis vous faites autre chose quoi
difficile de trouver d'être d'être
captivé par un interrupteur et une
ampoule quand on regarde des circuits
électroniques ou le fonctionnement d'une
centrale nucléaire il y a eu un moment
dans ma scolarité où vraiment j'étais au
fond du trou c'était vraiment l'échec
complet et j'ai un enseignant qui m'a
remis le pierétrier ça a tenu 2 3 ans en
tout cas ça m'a permis de reprendre
confiance et bien du jour où j'ai eu
ça parfois on a eu tendance à faire tout
de suite une un lien de causalité en
disant il a ces difficultés là parce que
il est à haut potentiel je trouve ça
très dangereux c'est c'est beaucoup plus
consensuel de dire à une famille ah bah
Monsieur Madame votre enfant est surdoué
c'est beaucoup plus facile de dire ça à
des parents hein la raison de tout ce
malheur c'est une qualité nous psy ne
rencontrons que des enfants en
souffrance à priori donc on a le
sentiment enfin certains
P pas très rigoureux ont véhiculé cette
association entre l'intelligence élevé
et le malheur mais c'est tout à fait
injustifié il y a des sujets qui parfois
gâchent leur potentialité euh pour des
facteurs à cause de facteurs qui n'ont
rien à voir avec
l'intelligence comme si c'était hier
j'ai 5
ans depuis l'arrière de la voiture je
perçois l'inquiétude de mon père dans
son
[Musique]
regard ces lunettes sarrache de son
visage ça tourne je me cramponne
[Musique]
verrais-je la fin de cette
[Applaudissements]
journée ma petite sœur n'est pas avec
nous elle fait la sieste à la
maison juste à côté de moi les brides
vert transpent son petit siège
auto à partir de là rien ne sera plus
comme avant
[Musique]
l'insouciance de l'enfance a laissé
place à une anxiété
permanente elle a su parler très tôt et
quand elle a commencé à parler elle elle
posait beaucoup de questions autour de
la mort des questions autour de
l'existence de la terre de la création
du monde des choses assez mystiques
quand j'ai su quand le diagnostic a étéé
même si j'avais de forte doute sinon je
serais pas allé la faire tester je l'ai
pas du tout pris comme une bonne
nouvelle moi j'ai perdu mon père avant
quea soit née
elle était très affectée de pas
connaître son grand-père un jour elle
avait 3 ans et quelques wi a fait une
réflexion autour de ça en disant mais
que elle elle l'avait pas connu donc il
pouvait pas exister en elle puisqu'elle
l'avait pas connu puisquelle n'existait
pas et puis tout d'un coup elle M
regarder elle m'a dit mais en fait si
j'existais déjà puisque avant de m'avoir
papa et toi vous m'avez imaginé bon elle
avait 3 ans et et en fait je suis restée
un peu estomaqué devant un truc pareil
et je trouvais qu'elle avait raison en
fait je lu ai dit que oui c'était vrai
elle avait raison elle existait déjà
puisquelle existait dans notre
imaginaire et en fait je pense que ça a
été la réflexion qui a un peu déclencher
le fait que je me suis dit qu'il fallait
enfin faire un bilan ils vont par
exemple se poser des questions
métaphysiques à un âge où ils sont pas
toujours prêts à pouvoir faire face à à
l'angoisse vertigineux par exemple de
l'infini des questions de de la mort et
après la mort enfin des choses comme ça
donc quand vous vous posez ces questions
là et que vous avez 7 ans alors que
c'est des questions qu'on se pose plutôt
à l'adolescence c'est pas évident
j'aimais pas l'école parce que je
m'ennuyais un peu quand même en classe
parce que c'était pas trop des trucs que
j'avais spécialement envie d'étudier je
me détestais pour être précoce et pour
être comme ça en primaire il comprenais
pas que je préfère passer ma majorité du
temps avec des livres qu'avec des gens
et que au collège enfin les adultes
surtout mon tuteur enfin on me comprend
donc c'est quand même quelque chose
d'assez nouveau tu as dit aussi hier tu
t'auras tous les jours elle aura aimé
voilà pas juste une fois par semaine
tous les jours donc que ça fonctionne
bien si tu en demandes plus ah ouais bah
oui parce que j'ai à chaque fois je
pourrais rester là encore une heure
parce que j'ai pas fini de tout lui dire
souvent c'est des élèves qui ont une
personnalité assez forte même quand ils
sont réservés au fond ils ont souvent
une grande richesse intérieure une
grande curiosité intellectuelle et donc
S ne rencontre pas un environnement qui
est à l'écoute de cette particularité là
ça peut effectivement être source de
souffrance
de décrochage de désintérêts d'ennui un
enfant qui a des troubles d'attention
ben on va essayer d'adapter les choses
pour que ça puisse aller un enfant qui a
une dyslexie on va aussi adapter un peu
les choses donc je crois que c'est un
peu un devoir pour moi de l'école d'être
à l'écoute des besoins de chacun à son
jeune âge Léopold a déjà traversé de
lourdes épreuves à 3 ans ses parents se
séparent lorsque son père meurt il n'a
que 6 ans durant cette même année de CP
on lui fait sauter une classe très vite
on lui diagnostique un trouble du
déficit de laattention le Tdh il est
alors réorienté vers une classe
spécialisée une classe ulice pour les
élèves en situation de handicap traité
avec de l'aritaline un médicament qui
régulent l'hyperactivité léop régresse
mais son au potentiel est finalement
identifié par un psychologue sa mère
apprend l'existence du dispositif
d'intégration des élèves à haut
potentiel mis en place au collège George
brass
très bien alors je pense que ça mérite
d'être relu poulette et le renard le
renard s'incrusta dans le congrès annuel
du club des Amis des poules afin de
croquer quelques animaux à plume
poulette j'étais avant dans un collège
où ça se passait plutôt mal enfin
c'était l'URE où mon Tdh était un peu
beaucoup développé en fait enfin c'était
beaucoup développé et je faisais
beaucoup de bêtises et
euh et jeis c'est pas mon travail en
fait je pense que c'est parce que je me
sentais pas trop à ma place surtout
quand ils m'ont mis dans en classeice
oui ça tu te sentais pas à ta place en
effet il y a jamais eu de de de
résultats de mauvais résultats il y a
juste eu un arrêt du travail je regrette
que qu'il n'y ait pas d'observatoire de
la scientificité
des psychologues qui s'expriment dans
les médias parce que ça aurait évité un
grand nombre de professionnels et de
familles et d'enfants évidemment tout
tout particulièrement d'être fourvoyé
dans des explorations diagnostiques
flottantes et dans des diagnostiques
infructueux voire cruel pour le destin
des enfants quand on a déménagé dans 19e
arrondissement et bien j'ai donc changé
de collège et là ça se passe beaucoup
mieux j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai je pas j'ai
pas été collé une seule fois je fais mon
travail j'ai des Bones notes quand il y
a un décalage entre la façon de penser
de l'autre avec la sienne enfin trop
gros décalage et puis aussi une vivacité
d'esprit vraiment avoir tout de suite la
réponse un répondant comme ça qui fusle
enfin c'est assez impressionnant et un
côté aussi solitaire enfin ne pas trop
supporter le bruit ne pas voilà avoir du
mal à communiquer avec les autres le
bruit je oui le bruit par exemple
leéopold supporte pas de manger à la
cantine je je fais pasop de bruit je
fais pas des crises hein c'est juste que
ça me dérange vraiment beaucoup je pas
des des crises non tu peux tu pourrais
mais c'est compliqué je pourrais faire
des non non non non tu pourrais manger à
la cantine ah je lui fais des paniers
repas h donc il mange en salle à 120
avec Madame le
Maire parce que je me rappelle donc en
petit comité voilà ça va Paul très bien
et vous monsieur ça va comment s'est
passé la semaine et ben elle s'est très
bien passé ce matin j'ai fait un
contrôle d'anglais qui c'est très bien
passé sur les métiers et par rapport à
ce que tu me disis la dernière fois sur
le fait que tu étais un peu fatigué euh
bah je suis toujours un peu fatiguée
parce que ce matin je me suis levé un
peu un petit peu tôt et un petit peu
parce que moi je trouve que tu es un peu
différent quand même avec avec ritalie
naissent oui ah bah comment bah comme je
te disais la dernière fois je te trouve
plus plus vif mais tu réponds très vite
et plus ah oui avec laitaline j'étais
toujours très très fatigué
ou là je suis un peu moins mais u donc
là tu es plus oui tu es plus vivant on
va dire oui mais je ve dire quand sur en
classe sur la concentration tu arrives à
rester sur sur une tâche sans avoir un
moment besoin de de regarder ailleurs ou
de toi toi ça va il y a pas de souci non
pas de souci non mais c'est ça le plus
important si tu sens vraiment que c'est
difficile il faut le il faut le dire non
non c'est pas difficile avec les
troubles de l'attention hein parfois ça
peut masquer le le potentiel parce que
ils arrivent pas à tenir en place il
bougent beaucoup ils sont distraits et
alors à nouveau on a tendance un peu à
les les qualifier de pas très malin et
parfois les enseignants vont les
disqualifier et le testing est plus
compliqué aussi donc on peut parfois se
tromper là aussi c'est important que
soit fait par un professionnel compétent
vraiment un psychologue clinicien qui
sait ce que c'est une dyslexie qui sait
ce que c'est un Tdh qui sait ce que
c'est un trouble du spectre de l'autisme
et
cetera Arthur testé en même temps que
son frère est TIF au potentiel on lui
diagnostique aussi une dyslexie que
l'entourage ne soupçonnait pas du tout
certaines épreuves du test au potentiel
j'étais incapable mais vraiment
incapable de de les faire on me donnit
une suite de nombre je devais la dire
dans l'autre sens j'étais incapable de
le faire incapable il a été diagnostiqué
dyslexique en fin CE1 c'est-àdire que
jusqu'avant le la fin de CE1 on avait
l'impression que Arthur lisait ça se
voyait pas donc effectivement le haut
potentiel lui a donné des capacités pour
que tout ça soit masqué jusqu'à ce que
ben il y ait plus de stratégie possible
à un moment donné il faut savoir lire
parce qu'on peut pas faire
ça par exemple quand on était petit on
nous donnait des histoires faciles petit
chaperon rouge trois lignees par page je
connaissais l'histoire par cœur donc je
je décodais à peu près difficilement les
deux premières lettres je avec le
contexte je
connaissais le grand méchant loup
attrapa le chapuron rouge et sa
grand-mère ça va voilà par contre quand
on nous sort un texte qui vient de je ne
sais où là
je j'observe chez certains enfants et
chez certains adultes un
surinvestissement un peu défensif de la
pensée c'est-à-dire
une propension à utiliser l'intelligence
la réflexion la maîtrise culturelle
d'information comme une défense ça peut
protéger de certaines effractions de
certaines anxiétés et cetera problème et
dans le cas de développer et factoriser
si tu fais deux étapes dans le calcul
c'est autorisé pour un groupe avec des
rapidités d'exécution des tâches très
variables un élève diè quand il a saisi
une notion il va avoir tendance à la
saisir dans son ensemble et ces
mécanismes
casul àes fameuses limit alors que nous
déjà on veut dans un premier temps faire
en sorte que le groupe classe comprenne
le cas général 2,5 cm ex dont on se rend
compte qu'il y a problème assez général
c'est des problèmes dénoncés c'estàdire
que l'élève est complètement en capacité
voire à les connaissances pour résoudre
les problèmes mais est en difficulté
parce que il a mal mal compris l'énoncé
ou il manque de confiance en lui je
prends l'exemple de Léopold mais il est
pas seul dans la classe de pas répondre
à la
question d'aller plus loin que la
question et pas répondre à la question
donc il a pas les points de la question
parce que la question est simple bête et
méchante il a deux actions différentes
alors d'abord donc c'est des
précipitations cognitives le fait
d'investir la pensée avec autant
d'appétit parce qu' dans la
précipitation on court quand même plus
vite que les autres ça témoigne d'un
voilà d'un appétit pour pour pour la
réflexion pour la pensée donc on n'est
pas très étonné que ces enfants se
retrouvent parfois à avoir un cuit élevé
parce qu'ils aiment réfléchir ils
aiment se remplir de d'information ce
qui peut être très intéressant justement
c'est le fait de les solliciter en tant
qu'aide aux autres camarades je suis
convaincue que ce ne sont pas les
centres d'intérêt qui font le lien entre
enfants je pense que ce qui écarte les
enfants les uns des autres c'est des
dynamiques affectives des dynamiques
relationnelles un enfant qui est odieux
avec ses camarades qui est complètement
désinhibé qui impose sa loi qui dit tout
ce qu'il pense et fait tout ce qu'il
veut faire change les règles des jeux et
cetera sera mis à l'écart par le groupe
de toute façon les enfants consultants
qu'ils aient un QI élevé ou pas
évidemment ils sont immatures les
potentialités c'est quelque chose qu'on
va activer c'est plutôt l'intelligence
c'est un peu un outil au service de
l'apprentissage et l'apprentissage est
pas déterminé que par notre intelligence
il est déterminé par nos intérêts notre
motivation euh le contexte social dans
lequel on est je vois des enfants qui
sont parfois même en difficulté
psychologique parce que dans l'école ils
sont
[Musique]
harcelés
nous on privilégie systématiquement
l'arrivée en 6e parce qu'on estime qu'il
y a différentes phases et étapes qui
doivent être mis en place quand les
enfants arrivent en 4e en 3e c'est très
compliqué c'est des enfants qui arrivent
extrêmement fragilisés on a de la phobie
scolaire on a des enfants vraiment qui
qui n'ont plus du tout confiance en
l'école qui sont complètement cassé par
le
système
[Musique]
l'être humain n'est pas un très bon
observateur n'est pas nécessairement un
bon juge qu'il est victime de beaucoup
on a beaucoup beaucoup étudié ces
dernières années en psychologie social
les billet de jugement et donc
simplement se baser sur son jugement
intuitif ne garantit pas du tout de
faire un bon
jugement en primaire disait que mon mon
fils avait des problèmes de de mémoire
de concentration a toujours évoqué des
moins jamais des plus on s'est jamais
demandé si mon fils s'ennuya en classe
alors que moi je je l'ai déjà évoqué
avec des professeurs principaux en
disant mais peut-être qu'il s'ennuie
voilà bon donc on a on a jamais été
entendu en cours préparatoire elle 15
jours après la rentrée avait déjà fait
des groupes elle avait déjà fait des
groupes de niveau les mauvais avec les
mauvais les moyens les bons voilà mon
fils était avec les mauvais
[Musique]
mais ça c'était ça le problème en fait
j'aurais dû arrivé sûrement un an avant
à George rissens merci à tous d'être
venu Adrien ouais du coup j'ai trois
élèves alors on va commencer avec Ilias
en 3e Wolf c'est un élève qui était en
échec scolaire l'année l'année dernière
qui allait plus dans son collège et il
estimait que il avait été un peu enfin
même carrément harcelé par les adultes
du de son ancien collège donc voilà le
gros point positif c'est qu'il a renoué
la confiance avec l'institution les
adultes h ça c'est quand même un un gros
point pour pour brassins le revers de la
médaille c'est qu'il sent tellement à
l'aise que il suit pas tellement on lui
demande de participer il participe pas
bah c'est un peu la la cata avec les
orientations ça se passe bien en techno
en sport en art mais voilà c'est tout on
se retrouve ouais là on se retrouve dans
un un plus dans jeun là complètement que
chercher ouais dans une impasse déjà
juste à voir quelqu'un avec qui tu peux
parler donc
bah ça change beaucoup de mon ancien
établissement parce que tu pouvais
parler à
personne c'est vrai qu' début d'année et
milieu d'année c'était pas les résultats
étaient pas fameux
mais j'ai je me je me suis beaucoup
amélioré au niveau des notes vers la fin
d'année c'est ça qui m'a permis de
pouvoir être accepté en seconde générale
trop bien il s'occupa beaucoup plus de
toi
prêtait plus attention juste de dire que
tu as fait un bon boulot que que le
travail est bien que je me suis investi
bah c'est ça fait du bien d'entendre ça
quoi il y a certains enseignants aussi
qui n' qui n'ont pas forcément les
connaissance également pour voir
derrière peut-être un élève qui pose des
problèmes de comportement qui a des
résultats un peu décevants en fait un
élève qui a de grandes capacités
l'histoire personnelle d'Ili m'voque ma
propre histoire il n toujours simple
quand un élève ne s'épanouit pas à
l'école de faire entendre ses ambitions
à propos de son avenir des décisions
importantes peuvent être prises à un âge
précoce malheureusement certains
raccourcis empruntés ces dernières
années amènent certains parents à
attribuer le mal-être de leur enfants à
leur grande capacités
intellectuelle un jour j'ai rencontré
une jeune fille qui était vraiment
brillantissime elle ne pouvait pas
s'arrêter de lire et de se renseigner en
PER permanence elle était vraiment
décrochée des intérêts des autres elle
était aussi assez agressive avec les
autres elle était fâchée et cetera j'ai
rencontré sa maîtresse directeur de son
école et cetera on a fait des réunions
et j'ai dit écoutez franchement il faut
lui faire sauter au moins une classe
parce que là cet enfant s'ennuie trop
quoi elle est vraiment décroché de des
affinités des autres cétait au début de
ma carrière donc j'ai cédé à cette
facilité cette illusion que la
souffrance de cet enfant pouvait être
guérie entre guillemets par un
aménagement du cadre scolaire
et le résultat c'est que l'année d'après
elle est devenue boulimique c'est que
l'avidité qui avait diffusé dans la
pensée avait été rassasiée et donc elle
s'était
déplacée ailleurs il y avait une
séparation entre les parents qui étaient
terriblement douloureus une mère qui
n'allait pas très bien à laquelle elle
se défendait de ressembler en
intellectualisant beaucoup en fait
j'aurais pu lui faire sauter toutes les
classes qu'elle voulait c'était pas là
le problème le noyau de la souffrance de
de cette en enfant était bien dans dans
son vivier familial donc ça é idée
d'être trop intelligent pour être
heureux est un slogan marketing
[Musique]
malhonnête lorsque j'allais à l'école
j'y allais comme un non pas un touriste
j'étais pas touriste hein j'étais pas au
club M mais comme un
passant je me vere moi-même le thé bien
au milieu du bol le sucre doit être
vertical sinon c'est le bazar ensuite je
range tout je range les momes je range
les gosses c'est sensiblement la même ch
d'ailleurs je range la voiture et
j'astique le abres oui j'ai j'ai
toujours eu des abres les rayurs sont
bien parallèles s ce que l'on est au
potentiel machin il y a il y a une
supériorité intellectuelle qui fait
qu'on surpasserait tout le monde dans
les matières qu'on aurait des notes
explosives c'est complètement chimérique
c'est pas c'est pas vrai c'est pas la
[Applaudissements]
réalité je me crois digne de ta flamme
et de porter ton nom car pour m'avoir
choisi pour femme
faut vraiment que tu sois vous êtes
formidable je ne pourrais jamais cracher
sur le système de l'éducation même si
pour moi il est parfaitement imparfait à
bien des égards je pense que tu
taccorderas sur ce pointl avec moi le
terme d'assiduité je ne peux pas
l'associer à l'école mais je peux
l'associer à ce que je faisais
extrascolairement et mes résultats
étaient inégal hautement inégal classe
de 4e c'était vraiment pas la joie j'ai
j'étais complètement je je n'étais pas
bah épanoui ça c'est une évidence avec
mes camarades qui franchement ne me
confortait pas dans l'idée que j'avais
ma place dans dans ces classe et donc
Madame SARD de Michel a décidé euh en
tant que principale de me faire sauter
une classe alors c'était une décision
euh
voilà qui a été un poids ça fait un
reménage enfin je te laisse imaginer
tous les mais ça c'est fait ça c'est
fait son choix c'était pas de me faire
sauter une classe pour mon plaisir pas
du tout elle m'a dit Enzo moi je suis
convaincu d'une chose c'est que vous
serez plus vite vous sortirez du système
scolaire et plus vite vous serez épanoui
parce que vous pourrez faire ce que vous
souhaitez mais ça c'est un
cadeau remarquable
et je crois qu'il faut saluer les êtres
exquis qu'on rencontre comme
[Musique]
ça la couleur du vert brisé se reflète
sur ta main
ton sourire a l'air d'hurler que tu
m'appartiens tu es mien je suis tien ton
odeur me rend ivre de bonheur tout à
coup je ne la sens plus je veux respirer
où
[Musique]
es-tu je HLE mon impuissance face à la
mort devant elle je ne suis rien mais
j'aimerais être tout pour t'arracher de
ses bras et te glisser dans les miens au
nom de tous les dieux auquels je ne
crois pas au nom de tout au nonom de
rien s'il te plaît
reviens je vais t'on souffle ta voix et
ton odeur je veux respirer où est Dieu
partager avec la mort ne me convient
pas en général enfin j'écris quand
j'écris longtemps bah c'est plutôt du
fantastique après
euh est-ce qu'il y a des thématiques qui
se rejoignent bah il y a souvent des des
histoires autour quand j'aié crré sur
votre pad autour de la mort
surtout moi je suis dans des mes un peu
négatif et que j'écris des trucs et
benah après comme c'est sorti de moi bah
c'est un peu mieux début quand j'ai
écris c'était parce que je faisais tout
le temps des cauchemars et du coup bah
j'ai commencé à écrire des histoires sur
les thèmes qui me préoccupai au début je
je réfléchissais pas forcément pour en
faire mon métier
mais
depuis un certain temps je pense que je
me dis que ça pourrait être sympa en
vrai quand j'étais
petitein moi j'aurais bien aimé que
quelqu'un en parler avec moi de
littérature dans la cour ou ce genre de
chos et pas c'était pas trop leur
truc plus mature intellectuellement
parlant que la majorité des enfants de
mon âge sur certains trucs ça peut être
bien
mais aprs ça peut être pas ouf non plus
par rapport ressent d'intérêt avec mes
amis on rigole on rigole bien ça c'est
chouette
euh bah les trucs engagés aussi on parle
pas mal de politique dans le collège il
y a pas trop de racisme mais il y a
beaucoup beaucoup d'homophobie genre tu
marches dans les couloirs et on dit ah
espèce de gros
péd même ça devient une insultante robot
genre oh si tu me touches ça veut dire
que tu es qu oh là là me touche pas
après il y a du sexisme aussi
principalement en fait j'ai quand même
la chance d'être dans un collège
globalement avec des idées politiques
pas trop nulles mais après ça empêche
pas qu'il a des gens qui soient
complètement
[Musique]
stupides William c'est l'exemple même de
la réussite de de tout un établissement
scolaire il a fait une 6e très
compliquée conseil de discipline en 5e
donc il a failli être exclu du collège
4e donc déjà un grand changement et
cette année William on voit vraiment
l'évolution PRF le jeu de logique de
stratégie de réflexion que aller dans la
cour courir ou faire du sport car à
l'époque j'aimais vraiment pas trop le
sport pour faire du sport souulent faut
être plusieurs et le truc c'est que
comme j'avais pas d'amis ben je pouvais
pas jouer du coup je préférais rester
dans la
[Musique]
classe ma dyslexie masque un petit peu
mon potentiel j'ai certains résultats
qui sont super haut mais j'en ai
d'autres qui sont aussi super
bas au cours des expériences de la vie
j'ai réalisé que l'exploitation du
potentiel de chacun dépend aussi des
différentes rencontres que l'on peut
faire faut-il encore qu'il y ait un
dialogue entre adultes et enfants pour
moi le manque d'écoute que je ressentais
m'a parfois joué des tours l'école est
l'essentiel du quotidien d'un enfant y
arrivriver le matin avec la boule au
ventre est
intolérable tout le monde connaît quand
même le parcours d'Albert Camu qui vient
d'un milieu extrêmement
pauvre en Algérie et qui a un
instituteur qui était monsieur Germain
qui qui repère quand même ce petit
garçon qui est quand même doué c'est
très touchant le discours de Camu quand
il a été reçu pour son prix Nobel où il
a rendu hommage à son instituteur parce
qu'effectivement sans son instituteur il
n'aurait sans doute pas été qui était là
à ce
moment-là cher monsieur Germain j'ai
laissé s'éteindre un peu le bruit qui
m'a entouré ces jours-ci avant de venir
vous parler un peu de tout mon cœur on
vient de me faire un bien trop grand
honneur que je n'ai ni recherché ni
sollicité et quand j'ai appris la
nouvelle ma première pensée après ma
mère a été pour vous sans vous sans
cette main affectueuse que vous avez
tendu au petit enfant pauvre que j'étais
sans votre enseignement et votre exemple
rien de tout cela ne serait
arrivé mon cher petit j'ai l'impression
que ceux qui essayent de percer ta
personnalité n'y arrivent pas tout à
fait tu as toujours montré une pudeur
instinctive à déceler ta nature tes
sentiments tu y arrives d'autant mieux
que tu es simple
direct et bon par-dessus le marché ces
impressions tu me les as donné en classe
je crois donc bien connaître le gentil
petit bonhomme que tu étais et l'enfant
bien souvent contient en germe l'homme
qui
[Musique]
deviendra